all right guys I heard who are you most
excited to see here I don't want to
shock you got to ask you about season
three what can you tease what's gonna
happen to art sheet we start off we
start off our cheese important we're
gonna see if he goes to jail he dies I
can't tell you if he goes on
I've heard that the season three is
going to be very hot and heavy what can
you tell us about that there are some
hot and heavy moments that's for sure
for sure heavy I don't know but it gets
hot and is the hottest summer in
Riverdale actually what if you could
describe season three in a couple words
other than hot and Abbey what would you
tell the fan deep dark dangerous they
gonna react how much are they gonna
freak out they're gonna freak absolutely
just freaked out man it's gonna be
knowledge it's crazy dark I mean when
you guys are reading these scripts
what's going through your head on the CW
it's crazy work that's what CW stands
crazy work ask there's a lot of love in
the water over there in Vancouver or
Camilla and Charles stating what's
happening guys I think I don't know is
he in town South Mountain oh I think me
and Charlie tails are you dated you tell
us just about artistically what was
going through your head when you
recreated that mirror photo it was
really perfect Casey came out with the
idea we were both on my trailer and he
said take your shirt off jump on that
chair and let me just never show it was
just like that and he followed my orders
as he always does last question what are
you guys most excited to see for fans I
know you can't tell me everything but
what are you most excited for the fans
to see season 3 storyline wise for each
of you I can't wait for them to see kgs
yeah KJ's stuff for sure
yeah yeah but you know it goes up yeah I
think KJ an actual have some cool chef
weather which has been really fun really
difficult to shoot a serious sensible
scenes to shoot because we can laugh too
hard but it's fun it's really fun
[Applause]
[Music]